in the very very best shootouts man the
Kelvin Gastelum style bender fight was a
shootout that style of fight for me I've
ever watched ever it's one of the best
fights of all time has to be it has to
be and when you see style done to get
rocked in the first round
dropped you like holy shit I think it's
best thing that happened to him it's a
good thing I think it's a good thing for
career-wise and going for it's a good
thing he faced a little adversity we see
that he's not gonna get hit and crumble
you and I you got one you got a special
dude in style bender and how good is
Kelvin goddamn he's tall how fast are ya
he's so fucking tough and even after all
that I mean style bender was teeing off
on him in that fifth round and Kelvin is
finding a way to survive I mean is it
great incredible style benders face
looked like he was allergic to shellfish
Kelvin hit him with some bombs man bomb
yeah but I think it's also I think it's
good we saw we saw a Sonia get hit and
get knocked down you some get taken down
we saw what happens when he's off his
back look pretty fucking dude he's
reliable
he's transition step in a channel octa
who knows what the fuck would happen if
that was early in the fight angry they
were dry so I think he that that fight
force table and checked all the boxes
but also what's great about this is
Kelvin stock doesn't go down no if
anything like I'd watch that guy fight
whenever whenever and let's be honest
he's really a welterweight correct he's
super small for a dare until can make
170 pounds so can Kelvin it's a
discipline thing yes I just think there
should be more weight classes I don't
even think it's I don't think he's a
doctor boy Dana may as well 65 you could
text something no no one listens to me I
don't want him to really yeah I do I'd
rather just stay out here and talk about
it yeah I want you involved will happen
I've pushed it I've said I think there
should be a weight class every time I
get out of here we could like dangle the
carrot like yo we do a fight campaign
every time I 165 her fights and just
dangle that carrot yeah he surprised it
won't do it probably still wouldn't do
it it's um it's one of those things
where like I think they like it the way
it is if it ain't broke don't fix it
yeah but it doesn't make sense because
if you didn't do all these in turn belts
why not do 65
I think belts on belt on belts you think
they do it would think that it's watered
down they have too many weight classes
the people would just be jumping back
and forth from weight class which they
would be time out chaos which I love but
you would also have people that find a
weight class where they could be at
their best versus either have to bulk up
or have to drop too much weight and
compromise yourself but you're happy
medium for a lot of guys that are not
they're not hitting that happy medium
right now yeah we're not getting the
best performance but here's the thing
about
so if Kelvin should be one seven here
style benders a small 85 er yes you
weighed in at 183 up he weighed under
the weight limit so look at how big some
of these guys are oh my gosh Brandon
Davis 235 235
it was 162 it was Brandon Davis right
was it who said that well some of those
80 fibers like you look at Jacare get yo
Romero
gigantic dude I mean it's gonna happen
thing about yo Romero stop it like y'all
remember jack dude yeah that's a big
flex now bender could probably make 170
easier yeah fuckin 85 I me 85 sir a big
wake up yeah
that's why you have you seen the talk
and makes no sense style bender and John
Jones that's crazy what are we doing who
the fuck's picking up on that's just cuz
they're talking shit what would he just
the last card just just says yeah he'd
balloon back up 260 pounds yeah it was
Brandon Davis right yeah 35 he's really
talented it's crazy when I'm standing
next to this guy waiting at 35 cause I'm
looking at him he looked to all of 165
pounds some things you look so bees 510
he looks so big for that 135 pound
weight class like this is crazy
well Eve max at 45 fucking huge but the
UFC performance Institute gave me the
green light to do that Wow so they must
have know what they were doing
says David's fight with cost was a first
in the ban weight division said he
needed to make serious sacrifices to get
there he said he cut out drinking
alcohol shit and ran 20 miles per day
off the tear line in order to make the
wait by the time he stepped in
2:36 he had balloon back let me see this
dude he's really big man he's huge for
the thing is that the he was also he was
not just like tall but he's like he's
thick you can it's weird how you can
lose that much weight but why not just
find it 45 why kill yourself like why
hide a 45 he fought the beat you know
his last fight well yeah as a beat
Muhammad sharapov so beat got him in
that crazy armbar from the battle with
that black yeah yeah which is so nasty
from filthy back mount
feels nasty there's two that night woof
I know it's crazy that's a crazy move
right easy but think when I think of 185
was think of Luke Rockhold mmm-hmm he
shoot up man
yeah it's a big ass he's huge but then
Whitaker's not like I think freakish on
deck I think Luke's done with 85 yeah
he's at 205 now he has a fight lined up
already but I mean is he gonna stay
there as he's just doing it for one
fight are you sure you stay in there